well again thank you everybody for
coming my concerned about doing the talk
like this is that a lot of the room can
either be I know everything you're about
to cover I know nothing you're about to
cover and I've never used an editor so
my hope is that each person here can
learn one thing so out of like the ten
things I'm going to show you if you
learn one new thing if that is a win in
my book so David Wolfe ah I came from
Orlando Florida I am gonna be talking
about some cool things to do with CSS
the reason I wanted to do that is that I
am a developer for a living and I spend
most of my time writing PHP and
JavaScript there's a lot of great things
you can do but I think that CSS gets
underutilized as a language of its own
there are a lot of amazing things that
you can do with purely CSS that you can
completely redesign a site which makes
it really easy to help end users who I
can just say you know go to the
customizer add some code to this
additional CSS area though all of your
sites are gonna have and I can also
start teaching people a bit about how
the web works in a way that's a little
bit more accessible by that I mean if I
want to get someone started with let's
say teaching with some PHP we have to
set up a server you know we have to go
find a site to work on even if I want to
use JavaScript we have to have an
environment created sure I can do some
of it through the browser but it's not
quite as easy as simply pulling up the
browser debugger and showing somebody
you know here's exactly the bit of code
that is making this text this link
underlined in blue and bolded things
like that so it's a good way to onboard
people into the idea that they can
change things on their own websites so
first I want to make an assumption that
everything that I'm gonna talk about is
going to cover at least 95 percent of
your users if you're using Opera Mini
you probably already know you are and
you're using it first specific reason so
you're out and then if you're using
below like ie 9 some of these things
might not apply to you but everything
here covers pretty much everyone else
actually a lot of these are good on ie
as well so I'm gonna cover a few
different things the first two that I'm
gonna talk about our pseudo elements and
pseudo class
is a lot of people use them
interchangeably and I wanted to first
show some examples of each and talk
about what makes them different a
pseudo-element is going to create
something that doesn't already exist in
your document so that's going to include
things like your before and after to add
new pieces of content as well as things
that will affect existing content but
target in a new way such as the first
line element or the sorry pseudo element
or the selection pseudo element a pseudo
class meanwhile changes the display of
an excelent that already exists that's
when we look at the focus or hover links
or when we see if a check box or radio
button has been checked or not we can
also target individual elements and just
say is this the only one of this type or
is this the first one of this type or
the last one there's a lot of pseudo
classes that let you target existing
elements and then pseudo elements will
create new elements so first before and
after these are probably the most common
su elements that a lot of sites use for
a variety of reasons such as fixing
clearing elements to ensure that they
break well so I'm gonna use some
examples by the way they're all like
screenshots I took of things on my own
site so first I have comments on my site
and I wanted to make them look like
little speech bubbles so one of the
things that I did was used the before
pseudo element to create a little
triangle on the side of the comment to
make it look more like a speech bubble
so the code here is simply applying a is
creating a new element applying a border
to that element and then changing the
positioning of it you know I'm saying
absolutely position this and put it in a
certain area the specific code isn't
quite as important as the idea that I am
taking something that didn't exist and
attaching it to something that does
exist in this case the comment body and
then as a bonus I also of targeting
comments that are by the author of the
post and making them look a little bit
darker so that someone can quickly you
know scan through and see something that
I wrote in response to someone else for
instance
I'm also going to be talking about one
of the one of the selectors here the
content property but I'll get to that a
little bit later now as opposed to a
pseudo element let's look at a pseudo
class in this case I'm gonna look at the
first child element so if you have
installed Guttenberg on your site before
it was part of WordPress or if you were
just looking at the demo Gutenberg Post
you have probably seen this that you
welcome to the Guttenberg editor post
right so it has all of the different
blocks that are available to view now by
default the a line full element has a
margin on the top and bottom and then as
a calculated with to get it to center
and take up the full width of the screen
so that works well but in my case
there's this big white area here between
the the post metadata and the start of
that post and I didn't really like that
there was a little bit of extra spacing
that isn't there if I use other elements
it didn't provide consistency so I
decided to take a pseudo class in this
case I am saying if it is the block
cover block and if it is the first child
meaning if it is the first element
within that page the first one those in
the page excuse me
then it is going to have a margin top of
0 I'm just gonna roll back a bit just to
compare these two here so this is a
minor change but it's something that I
can do to say only when it's this type
of block because it doesn't apply to
things like paragraphs images other
elements that aren't doing that full
width then make it not have that top
March and make it look a little bit
better and look more like other elements
a minor change that allows it to affect
any post without me having to you know
go in and edit some custom CSS before it
similarly I have comments on my website
and I do like the fact that you know
there are spaces between paragraphs on a
paragraph saw the bottom margin but it
doesn't really look so great in a
comment there's that extra space at the
bottom that is you know that little
speech bubble doesn't look that great so
in a similar manner
I was able to target the comment content
class that is the text that's within
that comment if you're using default
WordPress comments and I just said if it
is a paragraph that is the last
paragraph in the comment then just
remove that bottom margin so I can I'll
just jump back and see that you know
it's not a major change but these are
the kind of things that just tighten up
the design a little bit make it look a
little better but not require somebody
to have to you know find any really
hacky workarounds to do all right now
we're gonna move into ones that are a
little bit more complicated by that I
just mean tagging on a few other pseudo
classes with others with the not element
what we're going to do is target
elements that are not of a specific type
so in this case again I'm just using my
comments because this was a great place
to full screen shots from in my opinion
what the design things I did I wanted to
have a little visual element here that
would connect a comment and reply
comment so I have this little dashed
line here that will connect to when
somebody is replying to somebody else
and the way that I did that was to use
that after pseudo class since I'm
already using the before pseudo class to
create the triangle here so I used the
after pseudo class created a dashed
border but very specifically I made sure
that it was on comments that have
children as long as the child is not the
last child so very specifically
targeting if it is a comment that has a
child comment but that comment right
there does not have a child of its own
otherwise I would have a dashed line
going down the side here you know that
doesn't connect to anything else so you
can write a bit of code that you say
apply in all of these cases but don't
apply it in these other very specific
cases it does look a little bit I say a
little bit more cluttered here where I'm
saying we want to get a comment as long
as it's not the last comment last child
and as long as it is
targeting that after suit element but
it's a good way to be very specific
without having to write a lot of work
around code originally the themes I was
using used like a special comment Walker
that was very challenging to update and
didn't work with WordPress plugins that
depended on default comments being in
place don't look at a couple of
properties I did mention that you know
we use the comment content property
excuse me and I'm just going to go back
really quick and take a look at these
before and after you'll notice that I
have on all of these content and then
just two quotes I'm just saying that the
content area is going to be blank so if
it's gonna be blank why did I put it
there in the first place the reason
being is that these pseudo
elements are not going to take up any
space they aren't going to be added to
the Dom the the HTML document unless
they have some sort of content in them
to make them display on the page so it's
kind of a hacky workaround but we use it
for pretty much every pseudo element to
just have a blank content area but you
can also use that content area to put
specific bits of content in so as an
example when I'm writing a blog post I'm
going to have a list of categories that
I have attached to that post so this
post here we have the category of
WordPress the assess code tutorials that
looks okay but it can be hard to figure
out where one category ends where
another one begins
I had a category that had multiple words
to it so we have a quick fix we're going
to take a look at all of the list items
and add the pseudo element of after and
then we're gonna add some contents there
a comma and a space that way there is
some separation there but does anyone
see any issues with this code as I've
written it I say yeah there's that last
hanging comma at the end of it so by the
way we could do this with PHP and use
the categories list function that's
built into WordPress that is already
pulling these categories but let's say I
don't have the ability to easily do that
I don't have you know way to edit PHP
files on this site
I don't want to create a child theme
just ahead minor edits like this but I
also don't want to affect the other
theme so I can just use CSS to achieve a
similar effect so you've identified that
it has an issue how about anyone know
what the fix is gonna be using not again
chained them all together so now I'm
gonna say the same thing it's gonna be a
list item as long as it's not the last
child and there we go we have our comma
in our space without having to worry
about having that trailing comma at the
end just a minor change between the two
but it solves our problem for us without
having to touch any PHP this one is one
of my favorites someone over here asked
me what my favorite property was I would
say object fit because it has improved a
lot of what I do in terms of displaying
pictures that keep a specific ratio and
take up a certain space without having
anything look really weird so let's say
you were somebody who you know like
myself getting up on stage here it's a
little bit narcissistic and you decide
that you want a gallery of photos of
yourself because I was like the easiest
thing I could find pictures of the ratio
different ways you know this looks fine
I have just the this is just a WordPress
default gallery with four columns and I
set a specific width and height so that
they would all look the same but the
problem is that some of these images
here you know are really squished or
stretched out in a weird way but I think
most all these are from WordCamp us last
degree anyway they're all like squished
ups that's a problem so one way to solve
this would be to use the object fit
property and say contain I want them to
be that width and height but I also
don't want them to get their perspective
destroyed so that looks better too but
now we have some that you know don't
keep that same shape which is what I
originally wanted I wanted them all to
look good in a block gallery together
object fit can also be used same as a
background cover background sighs excuse
me
the same elements we can use
so I use objective cover and now I have
images that are all the same width and
height but also keep their proper
perspective so you will have some that
are you know cut off a bit like some
people might be missing on the side of
these photos here I think my heads cut
off the top of this one but it at least
has the proper perspective and looks
better than if I just had them all
squished up the reason that I really
like this element you don't have to use
any sort of hacky work around with a
background size property anymore that
means that you can have an image that
keeps a certain ratio or a video if you
want to have a full screen video
contained within a you know hero area
let's say that doesn't have to be put
into a background element which means
that you can still have your alt text on
it so it can still have some
accessibility and SEO wins you don't
have to rewrite code you know you don't
have to like take one of the blocks and
WordPress or in your page builder of
choice and modify the HTML to make it
work you know you're just using an image
and adding just one piece of CSS and I
consider something like that a win where
you don't have to do a lot of hacky
workarounds to get the thing that you
want just one property object fit and
cover
there's also another great one that I
have started to use a lot more
frequently background origin so the idea
here is that when I do want to use a
background element for instance this
one's gonna be maybe more challenging
doing with the PDF because I originally
had an animation here so I have a
background image here of line the code
here is just a linear gradient of you
know it's all in CSS making the line to
make it look like a sheet of paper so
this can be good if you have specific
control over the size of everything on
the page but you never have that you're
gonna be looking out on different screen
sizes people are gonna be assuming in or
zooming out so they can read your text
better and that would mess up your
background element with something like
background origin you can control how
the content scales with the background
or excuse me how the background scales
with the content so in the case here and
I have it highlighted
I was probably harder see if you're in
the back what I changed between these
two images was just the padding on this
element and since I'm using the
background origin of content box I am
telling it to only change the background
based on the content within this element
not compared to the full element size
itself so this here and this here are
both using a background that is scaled
to fit the text sets in there without me
having to create a new background each
time or force the text to be a certain
size or force it to be padded in a
certain way where I had to change the
text size it would work the same way and
then my final thing to cover is
animation and this is also one that
works a lot better with an ad with an
actual you know animation gif on the
screen but animations can be done with
CSS only now well for a while but it's
getting a lot better
to make an animation you simply use the
animation property you set up some
keyframes so in this case I have two
going on and an apology's that it's not
actually animated here but I have to
make it look like a typewriter typing
this words out here I made an animation
of typing and I'm simply saying that to
take this the box that the text is in in
this case it says WP y'all stretching it
out from a zero width to 100% width so
it looks like the text is appearing a
bit at the time and then there should
also be a blinking caret animation which
is just a you know single pixel border
element that I just say to take this and
make it transparent and then at 50% of
the animation make it Orange so
basically halfway through one frame take
it from blank - sorry blank transparent
orange and I think thankfully that's it
thank you for having me
[Applause]